in our series a more perfect union we
like to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us so I had a President's Day
weekend and during Black History Month
we're looking at Thomas Jefferson's
legacy in the unbreakable connections of
his descendants so take a look at these
two guys they don't look alike that's
Shannon Looney and Lucien Truscott
they're related vladimir duthiers our
extremely network cbsn is here with the
story of their ancestral links well I
can't wait to hear good morning it's a
fascinating story Gail good morning
presidential estates have long struggled
with how to present the founding era
exceptionalism along with the full
history which includes slavery at Thomas
Jefferson's Monticello estate visitors
are given a peek into the slave
experience on the mountaintop their
latest installation the Sally Hemings
exhibit and it gives its most personal
look at this shameful chapter in
American history at the expansive
Monticello estate there sits a simple
room with white walls brick floors and a
single silhouette that represents the
life of Sally Hemings one of our third
presidents more than 600 slaves the
exhibit takes a definitive stance on her
relationship with Thomas Jefferson and
the children they had together
a story once hidden now has the
spotlight now I knew that slave owners
all over the south relationships was
safe so why wouldn't I miss Jefferson
Lucian Truscott is Jefferson's sixth
great-grandson as a descendant of Thomas
Jefferson I'll give him a run at the
place when I was a kid I jumped on
Thomas Jefferson's bed
Shannon Lanier is also Jefferson's sixth
great-grandson but he's from Sally
Hemings side my story's a little
different from Lucius and because when
we were studying the presidents in
second grade I stood up and I proudly
said Thomas Jefferson is my
great-great-great great-great-great
grandfather and the teacher said sit
down and stop telling lies come on out
and meet your relatives in 1998 Truscott
met his Hemings cousins for the first
time on The Oprah Winfrey Show The Oprah
turns to me and she says well Lucy now
you my feelings cause it's what are you
gonna do now and I went oh my god and so
for the family reunion he was bringing
the slaves and the slave owners children
descendants together for the first time
so there were a lot of people that did
not want that to happen and it also
could mean that their possible icon that
Jefferson was a rapist and they didn't
want that to be their ancestor they
didn't want that to be their hero
stand up here now they're really not
gonna like me the Monticello Association
separate from the Monticello estate
voted not to allow the Hemings to be
buried with other Jefferson descendants
in this graveyard this is your mom yeah
should the descendants of Sally Hemings
be also buried in the family without a
doubt that graveyard is for Jefferson
descendants and their Jefferson the
sentence 175 people on the plantation in
Jefferson say 135 of them are enslaved
african-americans I grew up at a time
when you didn't hear the word slave here
you could go on 10 tours over ten
different years and never heard the word
slave and now the tours you take here
are complete to us I feel good in
America now gets them the full story I
mean these two rooms used to be a
bathroom and they uncovered that Sally
and her brother lived here and if you
take the tour they go through
Jefferson's bedroom he says John Hemings
that aren't surely there that was never
talked about you were never taught when
you were a kid then you weren't and I
wasn't that slaves built Monticello the
Capitol the White House this country
would not exist without Caesar and Sally
Hemings was one of the founding mothers
of this country I like to think about
Thomas Jefferson getting up on on the
day that he wrote the Declaration of
Independence back in 1776 who made his
breakfast who came in and shook his
shoulders and mr. Jefferson it's time to
get up and write the declaration
independence slaves yet I'm proud of my
cousin for saying it and it's so true
because you know fifty years ago when
you come to Monticello they act like
Jefferson built this place by himself
and there were no slaves here and there
now put in context to the content and
telling that full story of what happened
here and I think that makes history
Richard what do you think Sally Hemings
legacy should be Wow I think one of the
legacies that Sally Hemis left her
children was that they know who they are
they didn't have to be silenced that
they were able to tell their story it's
one of the great things of my wife is
getting to know the rest of my family
it's made my life and the life of my
children so much richer we can prove
that after being separated by slavery
and by history for so many decades that
we can come together as family then
maybe the world still has hope out there
they can come together and leave their
differences but stop behind them and we
were able to get into that graveyard
where Thomas Jefferson is buried because
as a descendant of Thomas Jefferson
Lucian was able to get a key he has a
key that is a privilege that Shannon
does not have not gonna change do you
think I love this story love
thank you III asked Shannon would you do
you it's great that they're
acknowledging you as a descendant of
Sally Hemings but the real
acknowledgement is when you
sadly pass will they put you in that
graveyard next to Thomas Jefferson and
he says right now they can't but I
deserve that right I don't know that I
want to be buried there he says but I
deserve the right to be I should have
the option I love how Lucian is speaking
up and I love the two of them together
yes they were wonderful and what's
really fascinating is when Lucian
described Sally Hemings is a founding
mother of this country and all the
mothers and fathers and uncles who
this country he feels very strongly
about that help make history
yeah and it's amazing because when we
were there there were groups of people
that were taking the tour's and they
were hearing about it and I said they
said what's going on over here Vlad and
I said these are the two descendants of
Thomas Jefferson and one man from Iowa
an older gentleman said I'd never heard
about this I'd never heard of it I was
younger I never heard that story but now
I know we're together now yes we know
it's true thank you buddy thank you